il n'y a pas de danse il y avait trois
garçons qui habitait en dessous de la
famille d'albe et six spectacles et ont
été décapités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ba m thomas gâcher allemagne les eaux
reçu une roquette qui a tué tous les
mondes de leurs femmes et jeunes pour le
soffin
il s'appelle moisés sa dessous
[Musique]
ni les en bombardé chez d'arena côté de
ceux d'entre eux sont morts
dans la famille abou chadi il s'est
enfui ils ont laissé leurs magazines
valeur d'un fait
paulo aux deux marches à elle tout le
monde et aller s'abriter à l'école manou
le quoi l'homme
randonnée tout le quartier s'est vidé
apparemment pas défendre
[Musique]
et toi tu pars oil non je n'ai pas peur
de la guerre atteint deux frappeurs
dacquois j'ai peur de rien sauf du noir
c'est tout
[Musique]
ce vendredi noir comme on va le baptiser
c'est le premier ou 2014
ce matin là après des semaines de
bombardements
un cessez-le-feu annonce enfin un répit
pour la population de la petite ville de
rafah au sud de la bande de gaza
après des semaines de réfugiés dans les
écoles des nations unies les gens
reviennent massivement vers leur maison
pour constater l'état des lieux
[Musique]
il venait en voiture sur des charrettes
ou à pied beaucoup marcher dans les rues
une stricte mais pendant ce temps à
quelques centaines de mètres de la ville
dans ce champ prédécesseur le scénario
d'une catastrophe est en train de
s'écrire
une patrouille de la brigade givati une
troupe aguerris de l'armée israélienne
tout le secteur à la recherche d'un des
nombreux tunnels militaire du hamas
c'est alors qu'un commando palestinien
surgi d'un tunnel et ouvre le feu ou
faire de l' échange un palestinien a été
tué et 3,6 a signé son combi
aujourd'hui
on a entendu des coups de feu et une
communication sur notre radio militaire
nous a annoncé que nos camarades avaient
été attaqués
et lorsqu'on a compris qu'ils étaient
morts nous nous sommes tout de suite mis
en route vers eux matane orechkine
jeunes officiers de la brigade givati
est un des premiers sur les lieux
rapidement
un constat s'impose il manque un soldat
son nom avant goldin
il a été emporté dans un tunnel dont on
découvre l'entrée mort ou vif
on n'en sait rien
au nom de code animal retenti dans les
radios
[Applaudissements]
des troupes de tout sud de la bande de
gaza convergent vers le secteur
chez l'animal dans l'armée dès que le
code hannibal est lancé on sait qu'on
doit faire tout ce qu'on peut pour
ramener le kidnapper à la maison j'étais
fan automne mois m je veux c'est
important d'agir le plus vite possible
si tu hésites prochain tu diminues tes
chances
pendant que matt en arracher quelques
hommes se précipitent dans le tunnel
pour tenter de sauver leurs camarades
à l'extérieur une opération d'envergure
s'enclenche objectif cerner les
ravisseurs à tout prix tel le clos de à
10 heures les israéliens se sont mis à
tirer d'une manière épouvantable
la capture du soldat golden a eu lieu
dans ce secteur agricole pour couper
aurait 10 heures toute possibilité de
retraite
l'armée israélienne va créer un
véritable périmètre de feu qui englobe
un quartier de la ville sans se
préoccuper des milliers de personnes qui
s'y trouvent considère je peux témoigner
qu'il tombe elle bombe à chaque six
secondes
et ce pendant trois heures c'était
horrible histoire n'avions jamais rien
vu seul pendant les trois coeurs des six
dernières saint dizier
[Applaudissements]
sous terre la traque continue le tunnel
était presque dans la noirceur totale et
même avec nos lente
on voyait à peine à deux mètres devant
la
thirion deux ou trois balles à chaque 50
m de manière à pouvoir abattre un
combattant du hamas qui aurait pu surgir
d'un autre passage qu'aux photos
non
l'orage de missiles et d'obus s'abat sur
la n13 à rafah recevra jusqu'à 2000
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les civils sont pris dans une souricière
le pit à najjar de rafah est submergé
ambulances les amenait de partout autour
de l'hôpital
dans ce cadre il a tort aux environs
d'un kilomètre par trois
c'était plein de blessés sans compter
des réfugiés qui affluent par dizaines
on comptera environ 1000 civils dans la
cour sur le sol partout dans le peter
mais ni les ambulances ni l'hôpital
n'échappe aux bombes
[Musique]
papoulias pour l'hôpital a reçu deux
tirs au total
le plafond est tombé et l'air climatisé
s'est arrêté les et pour des vitres ont
éclaté de glace sauf de nos épaules
le docteur chiendent crois qu'il s'agit
de frappe d'avertissement destinée à
provoquer l'évacuation de l'hôpital il
reçoit un appel téléphonique d'un
porte-parole de l'armée israélienne qui
s'adresse à lui dans un arabe parfait
il croit que le soldat goldin se trouve
dans son hôpital
c'était un tableau il m'a dit un autre
soldat a été kidnappé avatar et on croit
qu'ils se trouvent dans votre hôpital
des nounours tôt lundi nous alors
récupérer sans quoi vous n'est plus en
sécurité cf
c'était une menace et à une menace le
soldat était à l'hôpital
non bien sûr que non je lui dis autre
message du monde
dans le tunnel de courage des membres du
commando israélien ne pourra rien pour
le soldat goldin divers indices
notamment beaucoup de sang ne l'est
finalement plus de doute le soldat
goldin est mort années j'étais
personnellement je me sens amer de ne
pas l'avoir ramené à la maison
[Musique]
notre camarade kidnappé n'est pas rentré
chez lui
[Musique]
by the end au delà des au terme de ce
jour n'est plus de 200 personnes avaient
été tuées mais oui c'est l'avion envoyé
ailleurs de nombreux cadavres que nous
avions placé d'or des congélateurs à
légumes des épiceries aux alentours et à
la fin de la journée il reste encore 65
dans l'hôpital sixty five qu'ils et
elles sont tous des civils
oui oui tous des civils
[Musique]
voilà
quel que soit le bilan exact on peut
dire avec certitude que beaucoup
d'innocents sont tombés ce jour là des
suites d'une attaque débridée dans le
seul but était d'empêcher la capture
d'un prisonnier israélien
[Musique]
dans les décombres d'un quartier de la
ville de gaza nous avons rendez vous
avec mahmoud al zahar considéré
notamment par le gouvernement du canada
comme un des chefs du terrorisme mondial
il est un des leaders et un cofondateur
du ramasse il nous reçoit dans sa maison
en reconstruction
c'est la quatrième dit il les trois
précédentes ont été détruite par
l'aviation israélienne et des hôpitaux
ils attaquent des enfants qui jouent au
football sur la plage
s'ils s'attaquent aux civils c'est dans
le but de punir la population
palestinienne est inactive
[Musique]
pour israël la responsabilité ultime des
morts chez les palestiniens retombe
inévitablement sur le hamas et ses
alliés qui cachent leur art et lance le
requin depuis les zones habitées se
servant des civils comme boucliers
humains
soulever ici la question de crimes de
guerre qui auraient pu commettre le
hamas c'est ouvrir un dialogue de sourds
qui ne sommes pas ici pour répondre à
cette question comme si c'était arrivé
je n'accepte pas d'y répondre des
touristes mahmoud al zahar rage contre
l'antenne de l'onu qui a aussi écorché
le hamas
si vous voulez un exemple de crimes de
guerre dit il regardez l'opération
hannibal à rafah voilà ce à quoi les
nations unies devraient s'intéresser
avant de traiter la marge de terroristes
malgré la démission de son président
william schabas la commission d' enquête
du conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'onu a poursuivi ses travaux la
présidence de mary mcgowan davis son
enquête qui n'épargnera pas le hamas va
aussi s'attarder sur ce vendredi noir
celui de l'opération israélienne
hannibal à rafah on conteste pas le
droit de se défendre
ce qu'on conteste la manière dont il
faut dire que ce vendredi noir reste
pour l'armée israélienne
le plus difficile à justifier cette fois
on ne peut pas prétendre que les
victimes ont été utilisés comme des
boucliers humains par le hamas à la tête
de l'opération
un officier controversé le colonel
offert binter commandant de la brigade
givati il a assimilé le conflit de gaza
à une guerre religieuse contre le hamas
il a déclaré après l'opération hannibal
ce qui kidnappent nos soldats doivent
savoir qu'ils en paieront le prix
le vendredi noir de rafah a déclenché sa
part de controverse en israël alors que
le grand public a découvert l'existence
de la directive hannibal fait
exceptionnel la bande sonore de certains
échanges militaires du vendredi noir a
été coulé aux journalistes yoav zitoun
du journal web
why not
[Applaudissements]
cette fuite d'un extrait soigneusement
choisis aurait eu pour objectif de
montrer au public israélien que les
officiers ce jour n'a pas eu un
comportement somme toute modérée fait à
noter cependant c'est la sécurité de ses
propres soldats qu'invoque l'officier
là
avant d'être acheminés a été ingéré un
mais faut que selon moi les commandants
de la brigade avait le contrôle sur
leurs trousses et le fait de crier à la
radio de cécile tir en est la preuve
on fera deux par soirée où chamakh
beaucoup automnale
[Applaudissements]
mais notre enquête montre que l'assaut
des troupes israéliennes n'avaient rien
de retenue elle nous a permis de
découvrir qu'un bras de fer opposait
l'aviation et des officiers au sol qui
se réclamaient des bombardements aériens
encore plus massif au cours de nos
entrevues cette révélation d'un haut
gradé de l'armée de l'air puis gâte les
troupes au sol nous demandait de
bombarder massivement toubab est un
homme tout bollaert mais nos
bombardements td très limité quand on
nous demandait une dizaine de frappes
nous lâchions deux bombes rock shoegaze
et c'est sur son site web
c'était une situation très tendue et il
le demandait tout le soutien possible
mais je suis fier de dire que nous ne
leur avons pas fourni toute la puissance
de feu qu'il réclamait
[Musique]
plus nombreux encore que les morts les
blessés de l'opération animal de rafah
plusieurs importants les traces toute
leur vie ma jambe a été amputé à acheter
ma femme a eu ses deux jambes amputées
mon fils a eu sa jambe amputée mon frère
et sa femme sont morts ouais là même les
lissiers ont été frappés alors qu'il
fuyait temps semble les bombardements où
elle a passé sept jours dans le coma
ce n'est qu'à son réveil qu'il a pris
conscience de dca temps ou qui avait
frappé sa famille
ce vendredi personne de l'assistance n'a
été tué la majorité était des enfants ce
sont eux qui ont été ciblés ils n'ont
pas viser la résistance où les militants
ils ont ciblé des enfants les civils
dans la rue
jusqu'à 150 civils auraient été tués
selon les chiffres palestiniens au cours
d'une manoeuvre dont le seul objectif
était d'empêcher la capture d'un
prisonnier de guerre israéliens comme si
dans la balance les vis des palestiniens
qui se trouvaient là n'avaient rien rien
pesé
parce qu'israël prétend que si les
palestiniens ont un militaire
australienne des zones y ait eu ils sont
obligés politiquement à négocier le
retour de ce prisonnier et les
palestiniens exigent 500 prisonniers
palestiniens en échange et donc ça
c'était insoutenable
sur le plan politique nous sommes trois
ans plus tôt et gaza est en liesse
on y fait la libération de plus de 1000
prisonniers
celle échange du siècle du 1000 contre 1
mille palestiniens contre un sol
israélien le soldat gilad shalit capturé
par le hamas cinq ans auparavant
6/10 réel l'apei ce prix c'est que sa
détention était devenu un psychodrame
national
[Musique]
ne jamais abandonner un ses soldats
c'est un credo profondément ancré dans
ce pays qui oblige ses enfants à servir
dans l'armée
[Musique]
en israël contrairement aux autres pays
les soldats ne sont pas ils sont hélas
nous avons tous eu des conscrits je
l'étais tout comme mon fils ma fille et
mon plus jeune fils ont été dans l'armée
alors nous finissons par considérer les
soldats qui comme nos enfants pour qui
tu mets ça ne justifie pas le décès d'un
seul enfant le fait qu' israël veut pas
qu'un de ses soldats soit pris
prisonnier à sept points de
justification militaire cette
justification politique
là vous avez à mon avis est mon corps
pour cela été un très net la commission
d' enquête du conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu retiendra cette même
interprétation dans son rapport final et
par de l'opération hannibal comme
l'impossible de crimes de guerre la
commission dénonce aussi l'impunité à
laquelle endroit en israël ce qui au
plus haut niveau cautionne de tels
crimes allégués
en août dernier des forces de défense
d'israël ont annoncé la promotion du
commandant de l'opération
deux colonels binter au rang de
brigadier général d'enquêter sur israël
pour des crimes de guerre mais personne
le petit getty sur israël il y aura
d'autres guerres les personne ne va les
arrêter
qu'il y ait ou non une prochaine guerre
qui serait elle en tire ou pas des
leçons
sa face même l'opération hannibal
restera comme une tache dans l'histoire
d'une armée qui se veut moral
[Musique]